at a security Summit in Singapore
defense minister Lee Shang Fu outlines
China's position and issues a warning in
essence attempts to post for a nato-like
Alliance in the Asia Pacific is a way of
holding Regional countries hostage and
heightening confrontation which will
only cause disputes and plunge the
region into conflict
the U.S and China are jostling for
influence in the region they've been
trading blame
accusing each other of provocative acts
and the lack of dialogue while many
analysts say competition between the U.S
and China has created uncertainties in
Asia Pacific the main message we've been
hearing at this Summit is conflict isn't
inevitable but the situation does have
to be managed delegates and analysts
agree that conflict in the region would
be devastating the question is how are
you going to get that calibration right
um so I think that is where everybody is
engaged in a little bit of guesswork
because the opacity of Beijing right now
and the difficulty of communicating with
Beijing frankly means that
trying to get the deterrent signal over
is everybody's best guess on Saturday
about 2 000 nautical miles away a near
collision at Sea the Pentagon says a
Chinese vessel cut across the bow of a
U.S warship in the Taiwan Strait where
it was conducting a freedom of
navigation operation with Canada
China says the U.S Navy's presence in
the strait was hostile it comes a week
after the U.S accused a Chinese fighter
jet of a dangerous maneuver in
international airspace above the South
China Sea China considers self-governed
Taiwan as part of its territory and has
laid claim to much of the South China
Sea
the best way is for other countries
especially Naval vessel and fighter jets
to avoid such accidents around other
countries territory what's the point of
going there as we always say mind your
own business
relations between the U.S and China are
at the lowest in decades and there's no
sign this three-day conference has done
much to improve them
Florence Louis Al Jazeera Singapore